alexis poulain fondateur du monde
moderne nous a rejoint
alexis poulain bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors votre
première réaction à l'annoncé des
nouveaux ministres qui ont été présentés
ce soir bien 7 déjà remaniement a minima
puisque sont récompensés ce qui pourtant
n'était pas n'avait pas brillé dans
l'exercice comme franck mystère par
exemple et puis on a l'impression de
retour de nicolas sarkozy roselyne
bachelot franck riester justement d'un
mât n'a beaucoup nos le maire incroyable
de voir tous ces sarkozystes ou l'ump un
minimum à lattes
ça penche à droite pour vous les avances
totalement à droite et surtout ça penche
totalement vers la récompense du carré
de fidèles dupont moretti à la justice
ça c'est assez surprenant et limite
scandaleux de nommer un avocat qui
portait plainte contre le parc national
financier il ya de cela moins d'une
semaine qui travaillent dans le cadre
d'affaires extrêmement sensibles
politiques
le voilà maintenant aux commandes du
ministère de la justice qu'est ce qu'il
y a derrière la tête des modèles macron
on a eu comme ça le juge moreau par
exemple au brésil qui a été nommé par
ball sonar au juge moreau qui a fait en
sorte que lula ne puisse pas se
présenter à la présidence c'est ce qu'on
appelle le lot faire est-ce que c'est à
craindre en france de voir la sportive
isation encore plus du ministère de la
justice que sous nicole belloubet voilà
le départ de on en parlera après mais
voilà les premières impressions c'est
vrai que cette nomination d'eric
dupond-moretti
c'est elle qui surprend tout le monde ce
soir comment vous la comprenez au fond
ce choix du président de la république
et du premier ministre vous comprenez
comment ai je le comprends comme comme
un choix extrêmement politique
extrêmement dangereux aussi je
mentionnais ball sonar ou et le juge
moreau qui avait fait sept
cette opération pour empêcher lula
l'ancien président brésilien de se
présenter à la présidentielle donc il ya
un moment tu as lease et le tout
l'appareil judiciaire pour empêcher ça
comment cet avocat très en vue qui gère
des dossiers extrêmement sensible t'il
pouvoir gérer ce ministère sans
s'immiscer sans aller chercher par
curiosité
des dossiers qui l'intéressent lui
directement il ya là quelque chose d
extrêmement inquiétant de voir la façon
dont les choses sont faites sachant que
c'est un ministère qui manque de moyens
alors peut-être que dans la tête de jean
castex celle des modèles macron avoir
monsieur moretti c'est pour parler aux
avocats par les hauts magistrats puisque
la justice se porte très mal en ce
moment en france c'est à dire que
quelqu'un du sérail va peut-être pouvoir
arranger les choses
j'y vois moi plutôt le verre à moitié
plein le risque en fait de manipulations
de du ministère dans un cadre de l'ô
faire ou là le mélange des genres est
totale et ça c'est extrêmement
inquiétant alors autres ministères qui
était attendu regarder de près c'est
celui de l'intérieur avec gérald
darmanin on le disait mais aussi avec
marlène schiappa ministre de la
citoyenneté me semble-t-il qui
travaillera donc aux côtés de gérald
darmanin ce choix il va plaire aux
forces de police selon vous ça reste à
voir
vous savez gérald darmanin il a été élu
maire de tourcoing
c'est dommage pour les gens qui habitent
tourcoing le voit la ministre il a dit
qu'il garderait les deux mandats donc
déjà là on a un petit souci parce qu'il
va falloir qu'il se concentre à 100% sur
le ministère de l'intérieur
donc je ne vois pas pourquoi ils
garderaient l'amérique tourcoing quant à
marlène schiappa je ne sais pas quelle
image et là auprès de la police l'a fait
le travail qu'elle a fait dans le cadre
de ses fonctions précédentes elle n'a
pas fait grand chose à part beaucoup de
déclarations malheureusement là il va
falloir reconstruire une police
républicaine sont ils les mieux placés
pour le faire
ça reste à voir rappelons-nous la
première visite du nouveau premier
ministre jean castex était dans un
commissariat à la courneuve pour bien
sûr dire là la priorité qu'était la
police pour ce nouveau gouvernement
donc m gérald darmanin qui a une affaire
d'ailleurs judiciaire pour pour un cas
de violence sexuelle
voilà qui dit beaucoup dupond-moretti
aussi dans l' affaire outreau enfin ce
il y a là une négation de la parole des
victimes et mâcon voulais faire plus
pour les femmes
voilà qui le nomme alors présomption
d'innocence bien sûr mais tout de même
quelqu'un qui n'a pas
un quasi tout à fait net compte tenu des
affaires en cours à l'intérieur
là aussi ça pose question et ça en dit
long sur le peu de le peut de fait que
font ces gens là des gens qui sont
victimes
alors le ministère de l'écologie
également un scruté de près avec une
femme barbara pompili ce choix quel
regard vous portez dessus oui alors
c'est ça fait partie de ces de s'élever
ambitieux qui sont prêts à aller à
gauche à droite du moment qu'ils sont au
pouvoir
barbara pompili c'est l'assurance d'un
green washing tranquille un green
washing c'est à dire cette campagne de
promotion de l'écologie qui ne sert à
rien ou fait semblant en fait d'aider
les grandes entreprises de quelque 40 à
faire croire qu'elles sont écolos dans
leur pratique de la pollution je pense
que barbara populiste sera parfaite à ce
poste comme elle est un peu de rugby
féminin donc elle ne fera pas de vagues
contrairement à nicolas hulot qui était
parti lui de manière fracassante
elle s'apprête à faire une écologie de
façade qui va tout à fait avec eux la
politique et la volonté de mon écologie
des modèles macron sauf dans la
communication donc elle est elle sera
très bonne communicante et pas forcément
une très bonne ministre de la transition
écologique c'est le bon gouvernement
selon vous pour emmanuel macron dans la
perspective de la prochaine
présidentielle
c'est un gouvernement qui ne fera pas de
vagues je pense puisqu'il a récompensé
ceux qui étaient là dès le début c'est
un gouvernement aussi de la continuité
je crois que c'est important de noter
bruno le maire qui ne bouge pas parce
que l'économie va être un des gros
dossiers de la suite des opérations
qu'est ce qu'il reste à ce gouvernement
environ 1 tenant en pratique de gestion
des affaires courantes puisque après on
va très vite rentré dans la campagne
pour 2022 donc pour noël macron c'est
l'assurance d'avoir des gens qui connaît
déjà qu'ils vont être rapides dans la
mise en place des différentes aussi
qu'ils connaissent déjà des dossiers est
ce que c'est le bon gouvernement
l'avenir le dira on verra comment ça va
se passer je crois que ça rassure
beaucoup à l'intérieur de voir
christophe castaner exfiltré ça rassure
beaucoup de français de voir nicole
belloubet simpson mais s'inquiète de
voir dupond-moretti arriver
et puis je pense que certains sont
soulagés de voir le porte parole à
revenir à gabriella talent et de ne plus
voir si bête indien qui s'est bien
compromis dans des mensonges sans fin
lors de la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus crise sanitaire du
coronavirus qui sera toujours géré par
olivier dahan qui reste à son poste de
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
là encore comment vous comprenez ce jeu
ce choix elle a aussi un dossier
extrêmement brûlant puisque cette crise
sanitaire n'est pas fini loin de là
qu'il y a eu et bien beaucoup de
revirements de communication beaucoup de
nouvelles stratégies que les français
n'ont pas très bien compris donc s'il
devait y avoir à nouveau une poussée de
ce virus dans les mois qui viennent au
différend semble le mieux placé pour
continuer de gérer cette crise il pourra
même demandé conseil à roselyne bachelot
même si la culture elle pourra lui
raconter ce qu'elle faisait elle quand
elle était à cette place là mais
néanmoins le message est clair il a géré
cette crise à peu près correctement aux
yeux de l'exécutif donc il va pouvoir
continuer c'était important qu'il reste
parce qu'on en avait déjà changé en
pleine crise avec agnès buzyn qui était
parti pour les municipales donc changer
à nouveau de ministre alors que la crise
n'est pas finie aurait été un très
mauvais signal pour les partenaires de
santé en plein milieu du ségur de la
santé donc c'est le choix de la
continuité on peut que le saluer en tous
les cas à quoi allez vous être attentifs
dans les prochains jours dans les
prochains mois on sait qu'il ya des
dossiers brûlants qui attendent le
gouvernement dossiers économiques
sociaux la santé vous le disiez le c ur
de la santé à quoi est-ce que vous allez
être attentif ya la réforme des
retraites aussi qui va être traité par
le premier ministre oui alors à voir
comment cette réforme des retraites va
être traitée de l'avis de tout le monde
les syndicats patronaux comme les autres
syndicats ce n'est pas le moment de
revenir sur cette réforme
on a d'autres choses à faire pour
relancer l'économie éviter les faillites
et éviter qu'il y ait trop de nouveaux
chômeurs qui arrivent sur le marché du
chômage je prends le marché de l'emploi
donc attentifs bien sûr à la politique
économique qui va être conduite le
niveau d'endettement mais aussi
quels sont les signes pour aider les
entreprises et pour éviter que de
nouveaux français entrent dans la
précarité
avec cette crise économique majeure qui
est devant nous ensuite bien sûr la
suite de gestion du corps en un virus ce
qui va être la stratégie de rentrée dans
les écoles par exemple puisqu'on sait
que les écoles sont maintenant
clairement identifiées comme étant des
lieux de propagation du virus de nouveau
cluster sont apparus dès qu'on a voulu
ouvrir les écoles donc est ce que le
ministre de l'éducation va le ministre
de l'éducation a un plan pour la rentrée
jusqu'à présent il n'en avait pas
peut-être qu'il va devoir travailler cet
été
et puis et puis bien sûr tout ce qui va
être de l'ordre de la réponse à bien aux
revendications sociales
que ce soit dans la police darmanin qui
a fort à faire avec les syndicats de
police les soignants bien entendu mais
aussi tous les autres qui qui attendent
de voir quelle va être la politique du
gouvernement à partir de partir de
maintenant
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
réagi à chaud en direct sur rt france
après l'annnonce du nouveau gouvernement
alexis boulin je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur du monde modèle